listening to phil
true age women
and Karen warning I'm la
do you remember the first time you
stepped foot onto a professional movie
set hmm I think it would been Tucker
with Coppola um I had I had a friend who
was involved in the film and I went in
and I thought wow would be amazing just
to watch him so I went in and I was an
extra and the first day it was 400 there
were 400 of us and then myself and my
soon-to-be best friend which I didn't
know at the time were chosen out of it
to be kept for two more weeks on the set
and then we were the only extras around
and they actually threw us in a scene
that I kept thinking I'm not going to
this isn't it doesn't make any sense and
they'd sort of written it at hawk and
the first a day yet come up to me and
said wow you know I'm putting you were
doing this for you so it was really cool
and then but sitting being able to sit
there because Francis always had the
sense of community everybody would eat
together and he was cooking and it was
just a sense of and the way that he
worked it was great to see a